we're looking at matrix multiplication
the idea of not just doing things with
rows individual equations but drink
these with all systems of equations okay
so let's see if we can do just a really
simple one and have a go at getting the
airside okay so those of you who work
here on Wednesday I'm going to look to
you to help me walk through this and
those of you who weren't here Wednesday
you'll need to pay pretty close
attention to see what exactly is going
to come out of this okay
so we'll do a nice simple one let's do a
two by two times another two by two okay
let's do some simple numbers like this
okay all right so how do we multiply
these things who knows we've start yep
fantastic so I might even just as a
mental cue a visual cue I'm gonna write
that down that's the order that we
multiply things by it matters here right
so matrix multiplication is not usually
commutator with let me switch around so
the rows by columns here is a row and
here is the corresponding column that
we're going to begin with okay
so I will draw up my new matrix that I'm
going to get by the way think carefully
what will the dimensions of my new
matrix be simply 2 by 2 this is kind of
an easy one when you've got square
matrices it's really simple
but in case you couldn't remember you
take the dimensions of each one row by
column to Rabbi column so you buy two
right and in order to make sure the
matrices can multiply what quality do I
need to have because they can't go yet
come up fantastic the columns of this
one have to match to the rows of this
one and then the result will be the rows
of this one and the columns of this one
hence she makes you okay so I'll draw
I'm making a bit wider so I can put my
calculation - okay
so we'll matchup now one by four plus
and then I go forward to buy to make
sense so there's my first one now where
do I go what's my next step
yeah I want to move from left to right
okay
this can't move any further - right it
must be this one that pops over okay so
I'm again gonna do 1 into x 1 and 1 does
that make sense
one by one one by two cool don't my vest
right okay so I've done this right now I
move down which means this is going to
move down I've had my zero at my 3 I'm
gonna do the columns again okay so help
me out what am i right it'll be 0 times
4 plus 3 times 2 good
and then again 0 times 1 which is 0 plus
3 times 1 cool and now I can evaluate
them all yet ok up in the corners plus
plus 4 plus 4 okay 1 plus 2 which is 3
that's 6 and 3 there you go and there's
our product okay just to remind you
right see each of these numbers here
what's that called each one if it we got
four what do they call their called doc
grunts very good dope right here this is
the cross part any questions
that's exactly right
so rows and columns match all good and
what you end up with is a three by three
all right excellent
so I know that's a sort of really quick
crash course version for the people who
weren't here on Wednesday but that's
okay now there's matrix multiplication
what do you think would be the most
common sense thing to do after matrix
multiplication
well now matrix addition I think we've
done matrix addition right now I think a
natural next step would be matrix
division but but now I don't he had a
good week last week but and this is not
his fault the funny thing is there is
actually no such operation as matrix
division now you might want to ask the
question why however we can still do it
I'll show you how let's just think about
how multiplication and division relate
at the moment I say something like this
by 5 equals 20 ok can you write for me
what would be an equivalent statement
for this that would involve division
instead of multiplication can someone
give me an example
yeah yeah yes it's been it okay there
you go so what I've got here is
multiplication and an equivalent
division statement right what this
really means though is that division is
a kind of multiplication isn't it follow
write this like so right this is just
multiplication but it's in Reverse right
so what should I multiply by to make
it's correct a quarter right a quarter
so here's the idea the division is just
an inverse operation of multiplication
so divided by something is the same as
multiplying by its inverse does that
make sense that make sense
now you can do the same you can apply
the same logic right with addition and
subtraction right
for example 20-7 okay what is
subtraction subtraction is just well
it's just like this relationship isn't
it it's addition in Reverse okay so this
is 13 but how would you write that as
additional what would you add to 20 in
order to get 13 negative centigrade okay
so far so good right so therefore we
want to do like matrix division right
what we should really have is well
matrix multiplication but multiplying by
and here's our subheading for today
multiplied by the inverse of a matrix
okay so just like 2/4 is multiplying by
the inverse of 4 to subtract 7 is to add
the inverse of 7 right what we need to
do is work out well okay what's the
universe of a matrix if you're
multiplied by that that's what most
wicked will that's what division
division is
alright question for you for its inverse
for multiplication is a quarter right 7
its inverse for addition is negative 7
now why don't you pull these numbers
from how did you know that that was its
inverse
apart from the fact that you know that
these statements are mathematically true
ok what's the relationship for instance
between four and a quarter I want you to
think back to last lesson I wrote it
what we looked at under there and then
you make sure okay I'm going to hold on
to that idea we'll return to it in a
second but I'm gonna push on it a little
more okay before I get urine it's
written let's come back to this example
seven and negative seven are also
inverses but for addition how do you
know that these are inverses this this
argue it breaks down now what is it
about these two numbers that makes their
inverses and what is it about these two
numbers that makes them inverses do you
want to try something
huh
now hold on a second this is exactly
correct
mathematically but uh buh so what like
why is this actually exactly what we
it's right yep good all right so we had
two different operations right for
multiplication the identity is one you
multiply by one doesn't change it's
identical right for addition the
identity is zero you add zero it doesn't
change it's identical okay
so therefore how would we go about
working out or determining the inverse
of a matrix and the operation is
multiplication if I said okay let's have
a matrix hey okay and following the
Keita's suggestion right let's make the
UM notation for the inverse of a matrix
a may be one right by the way this is
not the only other kind of notation
where we have inverses that follows the
same convention what's the other one
think you know this we looked at the
multiplicative inverse gives you
negative one the matrix inverse will for
negative one we've been doing some trig
haven't we right and if you have
something like sign that we have sign
with us and we're like when you get
introduced to this we bake a big deal
and we say that's not 1 over sine it's
not whatever signs right it's not like
this it's the inverse of sine
yeah it's time to answer another
question but yes kind of okay but the
point is that this negative one right it
kind of mean just just undo it
happy inverse that's what inverses do
right okay so what have I got here I
want to end up with hmm I'm not gonna
end up with one I'm not gonna end up
with zero what should I end up with when
I put these together hmm
well the identity for motivation is 1
the identity for addition 0 the identity
for matrices yes we'll do you remember
what this is the identity matrix and I
shouldn't say the identity matrix I
should say this is an identity matrix
because there are smaller ones this is
this is the smaller ones bit boring
right
and then there are bigger ones right
which will have 1 1 1 or however many
number of dimensions